turning now to a sweeping proposal on
gun violence not here but in canada
prime minister justin trudeau has just
introduced far-reaching gun legislation
that has never gained any traction here
in america nancy cordes is at the white
house with more on this where president
biden as you know is urging congress to
take action nancy a lot of people are
asking congress to take action good
morning to you
good morning and they are at least gail
beginning to talk there is a small
bipartisan group of u.s senators who are
meeting virtually today and throughout
the week to see if they can come up with
some kind of
framework for a way forward on gun
reform proposals but while they're
taking those initial tentative steps
here our neighbors to the north appear
to be taking immediate action
we need less gun violence
we cannot let the guns debate
become so polarized
that nothing gets done
we cannot let that happen in our country
the new proposal announced by canada's
prime minister justin trudeau would
freeze handgun sales and implement a gun
buyback program for military style
weapons those weapons were banned in
canada following a 2020 mass shooting in
nova scotia that claimed 22 lives we
need only look south of the border to
know
that
if we do not take action
firmly and rapidly
it gets worse and worse and more
difficult to counter
here at home president biden said
yesterday he wants to see tighter gun
restrictions too especially when it
comes to the ar-15 style rifle used by
the gunman in uvalde texas remember
the constitution the second amendment
was never absolute mr biden admitted
there is little he can do on his own
without congress and the votes aren't
there for an assault weapons ban but
this week the two sides will discuss
closing background check loopholes and a
red flag law that would allow judges to
take guns away from people who are
deemed to be a risk later today
president biden will welcome new zealand
prime minister jacinda ardern to the
white house she imposed a nationwide ban
on semi-automatic weapons in 2019 after
a gunman killed more than 50 people at
two mosques in christchurch when we saw
something like that happen
everyone said never again and so then it
was incumbent on us as politicians to
respond to that
unlike president biden prime minister
arden is able to take major action like
that without legislation one big
difference between new zealand and the
u.s and while it is a positive sign that
these lawmakers from both sides are at
least talking we have seen that kind of
talk before nate without results
yeah we need much more than just talk
right now nancy thank you so much